welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and wakanda forever is set to feature
the debut of two new Marvel antagonists
in the form of name where the Submariner
and atuma but I'm adding that these
aren't the only enemies that the nation
of wakanda have to worry about oh no
because I have a strong feeling that one
of wakanda's greatest enemies will see
their return to the MCU by the end of
this film using secret scenes that
Marvel Studios have been planting for a
while now for you C minor babies I am of
the firm belief that wakanda forever
will showcase the resurrection of one
Ulysses claw back to the land of the
living to cause more Sonic based Mayhem
in the MCU once more and I shall tell
you why I believe this my nerd babies
but first do not forget to head on over
to new rockstarsmarch.com where you can
buy our latest Obsession shirts inspired
by both She-Hulk and House of the Dragon
alright so if you think that I'm crazy
by saying that Ulysses Claw is coming
back for the third Black Panther movie I
wouldn't blame you because the last time
we saw Ulysses walking vertically was
when he was trying to dodge bullets from
his friend turned enemy Eric killmonger
which immediately taught him the lesson
of not doing business with a man
literally named killmonger because
wouldn't you know it killmonger would
end up killing claw In Cold Blood just
so he could use his body to Grant him an
audience with the wakandan throne and
many people in the world thought that
this was the end of Andy circus's time
in the MCU but I'm here to tell you that
you are wrong maybe possibly highly
likely because check this out much like
the Joker is Batman's archdemesis in DC
Ulysses claw was that for Black Panther
in the Marvel Comics and we sort of got
a glimpse of that when Ulysses was
acting a batshit insane while running
from t'challa in South Korea look just
like your old man
thank you
and the main reason why claw has been
repeatedly able to go toe-to-toe with
black panther time and time again in the
comics rather than you know being torn
to shreds like wet one-ply toilet paper
in a Wendy's by Black Panther's claws is
because his physical body was kind of
non-existent for most of his criminal
career because Ulysses claw did a little
thing called converting his body to
living sound some people do that it's a
form of plastic surgery
because when claw first met his future
arch enemy in the pages of fantastic 453
he built himself a massive machine that
was capable of turning sound into living
physical matter something called living
sound and used it to create a bunch of
animal constructs to take down t'challa
in Revenge for being the one who blasted
claw's arm off many years ago however
after t'challa bested him Claude decided
that the Sonic arm that he made for
himself was not enough and he shoved his
entire body into the sound machine to
convert his physical body into a body of
living sound like a maniac making him a
functionally Immortal sound-based energy
being like this dude Sonic body could be
ripped apart a bazillion times and he
could be able to reconstruct it back
together because he's now sound can no
longer die he no longer needs food or
energy to survive he's just sound and
sound is everywhere this being said I
believe that claw's appearance in Black
Panther 1 wasn't the end for the
character but rather a crucial step into
his super villain origin story because
so far on the MCU we've only seen claw
as a mortal man in mortal flesh which is
kind of weird however we do know from
Avengers Age of Ultron that Mr claw had
some really in interesting friends in
the past friends who have recently made
their MCU debut in the She-Hulk series
on Disney plus that's right I'm talking
about the intelligencia I mean
Intelligentsia who of course in the
comics are a secret team of the smartest
super villains in the Marvel Universe
headed up by the big brained leader a
villain who has recently been announced
as Captain America's Main antagonist in
Captain America New World Order and
together they've been able to do
something that only claw has really done
in the MCU and snuck into the super
secret hidden nation of wakanda for
their own purposes at one point in the
comics and as we can see in the She-Hulk
series The Intelligentsia is making big
moves in the MCU and are massively
interested in upgrading the human body
through technology and science like
they're all about just you know doing
weird stuff to the human body and this
being the case I can see claw's old
buddies at the Intelligentsia being the
ones who resurrect him and give him his
living sound form this video is brought
to you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light sleek and Industrial and it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky old old School
wallets that make you look like you're
smuggling an 80s car phone in your back
pocket it's ridiculous check this out
nice and slow and sleep there are over
three colors and styles including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium and it holds up
to 12 cards and still has room for cash
in the back and every Ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days and
send it back for a full refund if you
don't love it which you will and the
wallets have over forty thousand five
star reviews and it's made with RFID
blocking technology that protects you
from digital pickpocketers and they also
have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop and
this month marks nine years since the
ridge started and they're celebrating
with a special sale so get 15 off today
with free worldwide shipping and free
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use the code new rockstars find the
link in this video's description and we
thank Bridge again for sponsoring this
video and how will they do that you ask
by retrieving his Consciousness stored
in a super fancy vibranium arm of course
because as we learn in Black Panther 1
after claw got his arm cut dropped off
by Ultron to replace that arm with a
prosthetic a sound arm made from a
vibranium mining tool likely the same
technology that Sherry invented to
safely transport vibranium in the mines
now if claw had a prosthetic arm
connected to the nervous system of his
body so it could respond to his mental
commands there is a big chance that his
mind energy his brain waves were stored
inside of his vibranium arm because
that's what vibranium does it absorbs
energy and we already know from the
existence of Microsoft Zola in Captain
America 2 but the Mind does not need a
physical body to exist after death in
the MCU and if what if episode 8
establishes that there are multiple Zola
copies scattered around MCU Earth then
Zola could very well be part of this MCU
intelligencia team that could retrieve
Clause Consciousness and convert it into
living sound form using the technology
already in his arm and something like
that would actually be an adaptation of
what happened to claw in the comics in
the pages of Marvel 2 and 1 issue number
57 when claw's criminal friend solar man
managed to restore claw's living sound
body by throwing his arm against the
wall giving the arm The Sound Energy it
needed to retrieve claw's stored
Consciousness from within the arm so
yeah this all being said with the leader
and the Intelligentsia arriving on the
scene in the MCU literally anything is
possible with science and after wakanda
revealed to the world that they are in
fact the most advanced Nation on the
planet thanks to their vibranium
resources I have a feeling that the
Intelligentsia might just need cloth to
help them get a piece of that vibranium
pie for their own nefarious big brain
bad guy purposes and that is why he'll
be popping back on the scene but only
time will tell but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertonment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] and really fun
theories but of course you can follow
new rock stars wherever we are on the
interwebs and of course do not forget to
hit up the rockstarsmerch.com so you can
pick up our newest latest Obsession
Church inspired by She-Hulk and House of
the dragon that are not going to last
forever so pick them up today for you or
your children because we have child
sizes as well but yes thank you guys so
much for spending time with me and I'll
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]